how much would it cost to be Captain
America Captain America the Nazi weapons
super soldier from Marvel Avengers is
one of the best superheroes of all time
with the new Winter Soldier movie coming
out we decided to crack into the
financial breakdown of how much being a
superhero costs even one that runs on
government shield funds join us as we
dig into the calculations and pricing
figures of Steve Rogers Captain America
the First Avenger back in World War Two
a single unmarried man who at the
ranking of Captain in the US Army was
paid about $2,400 per year Captain
America fought for about two years in
World War two so that's about $4,800 he
could have saved up unfortunately Steve
Rogers was frozen in ice for nearly 70
years but if he had that money in a
savings account with a typical point
zero three percent monthly interest rate
from 1944 to 2014 his wealth would be
increased to six thousand nine dollars
and 67 World War two was very expensive
the United States spent more than three
hundred billion dollars fighting the
Axis powers and supplying our allies the
United States Treasury offered Americans
a series of war bonds they could
purchase during the war war bonds were
sold in different values and today
they're worth three point six times as
much if Steve Rogers had a typical
amount say a thousand dollars worth
they'd be three thousand six hundred
dollars today Abraham Erskine is the
genius who invented the Super Soldier
Serum we figure Erskine is about as much
of a genius as Albert Einstein and
according to an article in The Wall
Street Journal historical records show
Einsteins annual salary at Princeton was
ten thousand dollars in 1933 so we're
going to assume our scheme was offered a
similar competitive
shall we will put Erskine's market value
at ten thousand dollars add up the same
for genius Howard Stark who worked on
the project at another ten thousand for
lab equipment cost of the facility lab
assistance and research that comes to
thirty thousand dollars remember a Super
Soldier Serum was mostly developed in
Europe while Erskine was working for
Hydra against his well it was an
unfinished version that transformed
Johann Schmidt into the Red Skull the
shield is made of vibranium a fictional
metal that exists in the Marvel Universe
it has the ability to absorb any energy
vibrations which makes it indestructible
in the Marvel Universe vibranium comes
from the African nation will conduct
home of the Black Panther according to
issues 6:07 of the Fantastic Four Reed
Richards states that vibranium costs ten
thousand dollars per gram according to
the Marvel online database Captain
America shield weighs 12 pounds 12
pounds at $10,000 per gram comes to 54
million 430 $1100 Captain America's
uniform can be broken down to gloves $20
helmet $100 uniform $1,000 boots $100
belts $20 Captain America has had three
different outfits in the three movies
he's been in because each outfit is very
similar in pricing we will multiply
those numbers by three the total is
three thousand seven hundred twenty
dollars the standard US military handgun
is the Sig Sauer p226
which has a retail price of nine hundred
dollars shield for strategic homeland
intervention enforcement and logistics
division employees Captain America as a
special agent similar espionage and
law-enforcement careers pay between
$40,000 to $100,000 since Captain
America is the best of the best
we'll assume he makes around $100,000
year Steve Rogers super-soldier
metabolism burns four times the average
human male so he eats four times as much
food in 2009 US Bureau of Labor
Statistics found that the average
American spent six thousand four hundred
forty-three dollars annually on food
multiply that times four you get twenty
five thousand seven hundred seventy two
dollars per grocery bills cap rides the
2014 harley-davidson 750 which goes for
a retail price of seven thousand five
hundred dollars and last but not least
let's add in the price of all those
punching bags six hundred dollars when
adding up all the costs we get a grand
total of fifty four million six hundred
nine thousand two hundred one dollars
and sixty cents and it's a price I'm
willing to pay when adjusting variable
cost for inflation fifty four million
nine hundred seventy seven thousand nine
hundred twenty two dollars and five
cents thanks for watching be sure to
subscribe and click the posters to watch
more clips
[Music]
[Music]